en este su primer gran discurso desde
que fue elegido Richie sunak hizo cinco
promesas la primera reducir la cifra de
la inflación que en noviembre de 2022
llegó al 10.7% para lograrlo tendría que
bajarla hasta un poco más del 5% Pero
esto no sólo depende del gobierno
británico sino de factores
internacionales como el precio de la
energía también mejorar la economía
promoviendo el aumento de trabajos de
puestos de trabajo con mejores salarios
reducir el endeudamiento público de la
nación recortar la lista de espera que
tienen que tener las personas para poder
ser vistas por un médico o por un
especialista del Sistema Nacional de
salud en eches y una bien controversial
acabar con la inmigración ilegal a
través del Canal de la Mancha con una
legislación mucho más fuerte es decir
que las personas que crucen el canal
desde Francia desde las playas francesas
y lleguen al Reino Unido puedan ser
detenidas y deportadas inmediatamente ha
dicho el gobierno
solo en el 2022 cerca de 46.000 personas
llegaron por esta vida Aunque Richie
sunak ha presentado ha puesto sobre la
mesa estas las que son las cinco
prioridades de su gobierno Lo cierto es
que ha habido un momento de debilidad
política su gobierno porque todos los
días el país está enfrentando huelgas de
diferentes sectores públicos que dan la
sensación de una huelga generalizada de
una huelga general y sobre todo de un
Primer Ministro desconectado de la
realidad del país